[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 15 février voici le
programme de ce soir les syndicats
appellent à une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites demain nous ferons le point
dans cette émission sur les
perturbations à venir dans le
département au niveau des transports et
des écoles Thierry trevalinet le nouveau
président du Medef des Yvelines sera
également notre invitée quelle est la
position de la première organisation
patronale sur cette réforme nous lui
poserons la question jusqu'au 9 mars les
lycéens et étudiants sont invités à
formuler leurs vœux sur la plateforme
parcoursup c'est dans ce cadre que dans
votre cette huit nous vous proposons
tous les mercredis le portrait d'une
école du territoire ce soir focus sur
Buc ressources l'école spécialisée dans
les métiers du niveau social quels sont
les formations comment y rentrer nous
répondrons à ces questions avec une
ancienne étudiante et notre journaliste
Régine ralech et comme chaque mercredi
nous parlons également de cinéma ce soir
nous serons avec le réalisateur de La
Verrière Tony chasselas il nous
présentera son nouveau cours métrage
jamais sans mon tel sans oublier les
sorties ciné de cette semaine avec notre
journaliste Céline Charles et le coup de
cœur d'un professionnel du septième art
et en plateau du coup je viens de le
dire deux journalistes de la rédaction
de TV 78 Régine ralent chez Céline
Charles bonsoir bonsoir alors Céline
vous allez nous parler des films à ne
pas manquer cette semaine au cinéma vous
nous faites un petit teasing alors oui
au programme ce soir un biopic sombre et
psychologique le nouveau Marvel et un
comique français et donc ce sera enfin
d'émission restez bien avec nous Régine
vous vous allez nous parler d'une école
du territoire ce sera bucrosource
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit Buc
ressources qui est tournée vers les
métiers médico-social et donc pour en
parler avec nous Charlène Garcia bonsoir
vous êtes une ancienne étudiante de
cette école alors pourquoi est-ce vous
l'avez choisi pourquoi est-ce que vous
avez décidé de vous orienter vers cette
école alors tout simplement j'avais la
fibre sociale déjà en moi on va dire
c'était déjà des métiers dont j'avais
envie de faire et bucre source étant
situé dans les Yvelines ayant cette
avantage là vers le temps de pas aller
sur Paris ou de changer de région donc
on en parlera plus en détail tout à
l'heure en plateau avec nous également
ce soir le nouveau président du Medef
des Yvelines Thierry trévaliné bonsoir
alors première question qu'est-ce que ça
vous fait d'avoir été élu président
d'avoir été élu président du Medef 78
pour représenter mes pairs en fait sur
le territoire je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire dans les
Yvelines on a un foncier qui est
extrêmement intéressant et de ce point
de vue là et je pense qu'on peut attirer
beaucoup d'entreprises
de plus ou moins de grandes technologies
voilà et donc on en parlera également
tout à l'heure mais avant je tends un
coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin nous devrions être dans le
brouillard sur l'ensemble du département
selon Météo France au niveau des
températures il fera 6 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan et 5 degrés à
Versailles et Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi le soleil ne sera pas des
nôtres prévoyez un ciel couvert et côté
température il fera 11 à 9 degrés en
moyenne et demain nous fêterons la
sainte julienne le pont maintenant sur
les informations du jour dans les
Yvelines avec Régine ralech
la retraite à 64 ans c'était
définitivement non ce mercredi matin une
cinquantaine de personnes réunies à
Rambouillet à l'appel de l'Inter
syndical elles se sont mobilisées devant
la permanence de la députée de la
dixième circonscription des Yvelines
Aurore berger qui n'était pas présente
sur place l'objectif pour les syndicats
interpeller la chef de fil des députés
renaissance pour le retrait de la
réforme des retraites le texte de loi
est examiné jusqu'à vendredi à
l'ensemble nationale des Yvelines a
demandé une audience à Aurore Bergé à
Walt de début de l'examen de du projet
de loi pour lui expliquer nos arguments
sur pourquoi on est contre ce projet de
loi elle n'a jamais répondu à nos
demandes donc du coup on vient pour lui
dire qu'on est là qu'on aimerait bien
qu'elle ne vote pas ce projet de loi ce
jeudi 5ème jour de grève nationale
contre la réforme une manifestation est
prévue dans les rues de Versailles les
Yvelines ont officialisé aujourd'hui
leur participation au capital de Thoiry
bioénergie depuis 2018 l'usine produit
du biométhane à partir de déchets
organiques au profit du zoo et de 8
communes yvinoises le montant de
l'opération pour le département s'élève
à 2 millions d'euros soit 31% du capital
le cirque Europa et adcf association de
défense des cirques de familles ont
déposé plein de contre alira Bay le
maire de Trappes fin 2020 la
municipalité avait publié un arrêté pour
interdire les cirques avec des animaux
sauvages la DCF prévoit de fortes
mobilisations pour protester contre la
décision du maire
la région Île-de-France lance un appel à
projet pour donner un nouveau souffle
aux îles de loisirs francilienne et les
rendre plus attractives dans le
département des Yvelines ce sont les
trois îles de loisirs aval de Seine
boucle de scène et Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines qui sont concernés le dépôt de
candidature se termine le 31 mars à 17
heures
l'association handicien dispose
désormais d'une délégation locale à
Villepreux cette nouvelle antenne portée
par Anne-Sophie Sablon Maury permet de
former davantage de chiens pour le
moment ils sont trois bénéficier d'une
formation chaque semaine à l'école Jean
Rostand
[Musique]
on en parlait à l'instant depuis le 1er
février thierry trevalinet est devenu le
nouveau président du Medef des Yvelines
il succède à Zacharie Hardy Thierry
valiné vous êtes également le directeur
général d'AVL France depuis 2013 une
société dans le secteur de l'industrie
alors sur quoi est-ce que vous allez
travailler en priorité en tant que
nouveau président du Medef des Yvelines
je pense que la première des mes
priorités ça va être déjà de
d'assurer la continuité du mandat
précédent je pense que c'est un c'est
important on a redressé le Medef des
Yvelines en tous les cas Zacharie il l'a
fait et il l'a fait de très belles
façons donc c'est notre mission de
pouvoir garder cette continuité je
voudrais avoir aussi une cohésion entre
le bureau exécutifs les administrateurs
et puis les comment la direction
opérationnelle du Medef et puis en
dernier lieu il va falloir qu'on soit au
service de nos adhérents et apporter une
proposition de valeur à tous les chefs
d'entreprise qui vous ont bien nous
rejoindre je pense que c'est là qui est
le vrai comment à tout du médaille 78
c'est croître dans ses adhésions pour le
service de des chefs d'entreprise des
Yvelines voilà donc principalement
assuré la continuité mais est-ce que en
tant que nouveau président vous
souhaitez mettre en place de nouvelles
choses durant votre mandat pour le
moment c'est un peu tôt pour le pour le
dire sincèrement je ça fait deux
semaines que j'ai pris mes fonctions je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup de choses à
faire autour de des collectivités de
l'entreprise au sein de la collectivité
de de la formation également du
recrutement et et ça je pense que c'est
très important de pouvoir prendre ça en
considération avec c'est une société
internationale je vois quels sont les
interactions entre lesquelles en
Allemagne entre les universités les
industriels et puis les collectivités et
les régions et je trouve que ça serait
intéressant de prendre ça comme exemple
pour notre cher département des Yvelines
dans tous les cas voilà alors durant le
mandat de Zacharie Hardy le nombre
d'entreprises adhérentes à exploser le
budget a aussi été multiplié par deux
mais aussi ce contexte d'inflation avec
le covid la crise sanitaire c'est un
contexte un peu particulier pour
commencer ce mandat d'entreprise d'une
manière générale sont toujours
optimistes et c'est encore le cas dans
les derniers sondages qu'on a pu faire
au sein du Medef et donc ça c'est quand
même très intéressant que quand est
l'inflation ou les prix de l'énergie les
commandes et les portefeuilles de
commande sont quand même au beau fixe
donc ça c'est quand même intéressant
pour l'avenir je dirais proche voilà et
alors justement quelle est la situation
des entreprises yvelinoises d'une
manière bien spécifique au niveau des
entreprises et villinoises évidemment il
y a toujours ces portes ces
portefeuilles de commande qui sont
pleins comme au niveau national je
dirais
mais d'une certaine façon on est même
aussi très inquiet sur l'économie
française et on parlera certainement de
la réforme des retraites et ça ça nous
inquiète quand même d'une certaine façon
alors juste avant de parler de la
réforme des retraites un mot sur le
chômage il n'a jamais été aussi bas
depuis 2008 est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est une situation durable ou est-ce
que vous craignez justement avec ce
contexte social un peu compliqué vous
avez des craintes vis-à-vis de ça non
pas forcément enfin tous les cas dans le
domaine que dans lequel moi je pratique
c'est-à-dire l'ingénierie et puis donc
les prestations de haute technologie on
a du mal à recruter donc et je crois que
c'est vrai dans tous les domaines donc
je pense que c'est une vraie chance pour
nos jeunes d'intégrer ces gens de ces
entreprises et donc non ça nous fait pas
beaucoup plus peur que que cela en fait
par contre on aurait aimé qu'il y ait
une réforme de la location chômage de
façon à avoir plus d'agitée de
flexibilité comme on peut le voir dans
d'autres pays européens en fait
difficulté à recruter qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait vais mettre en place pour pour
essayer de rendre attractif certains
secteurs en particulier dans les
filières automobiles que je connais en
particulier enfin plus particulièrement
et plus spécialement je pense que ça
serait intéressant de mettre en avant
les technologies qu'on est qu'on va
développer dans tous ces domaines de
très intéressants que ça soit dans le
domaine électronique l'informatique les
batteries etc donc il y a des choses à
faire au niveau des universitaires au
niveau des écoles d'ingénieurs au niveau
des des des BTS des DUT mais aussi au
niveau des bacs pronoms toute cette
filière on a besoin de mettre en place
et je pense qu'on ne l'a commencé à le
faire avec les complices des métiers et
il faut qu'on continue dans ce domaine
là et je pense que c'est le cas dans
beaucoup des domaines venir
faire la promotion de de l'entreprise au
sein de comment des universités
au niveau national il y a aussi
l'élection bientôt début juillet du
nouveau président du Medef en France la
succession de Geoffroy roux de Baisieux
alors plusieurs candidats sont en lis
est-ce que vous savez déjà qui vous
allez soutenir
tout ce que je sais c'est qu'on va avoir
au niveau des Yvelines si vous donc au
niveau du vote et on va les utiliser au
mieux bien entendu voilà donc je pense
que c'est trop tôt pour en dire beaucoup
plus aujourd'hui alors on en parlait
juste avant la réforme des retraites
évidemment elle est au cœur de
l'actualité la première organisation
patronale est plutôt favorable à cette
réforme quelle est votre point de vue
sur sur ce sujet
également favorable mais je pense que de
toute façon il faut suivre un petit peu
les instructions du Medef national dans
ce domaine là on va pas en dévier
beaucoup ce qui importe pour nous c'est
que on n'est pas une dérive au niveau
des des commandes des dettes qui sont
engendrées par par si on ne faisait rien
donc ce sont des impôts supplémentaires
pour les pour les chefs d'entreprise
pour les entreprises et c'est ce qu'on
veut éviter après la façon dont on s'y
prend ça c'est du ressort du
gouvernement ce qu'on veut nous c'est
arrivé à un bilan financier équilibré
pour le bien de nous tous finalement et
pour que le régime paraît partition
subsiste et voilà et ça nous empêche pas
de penser à un régime par capitalisation
par ailleurs mais en tous les cas il
faut que ce régime par répartition
subsiste en tous les cas indispensable
cette réforme selon vous je pense parce
que en fait on avait aujourd'hui il y a
1, je crois 4 ou 7 personnes actives
pour un retraité 1,4 je crois de mémoire
et et aujourd'hui effectivement quand on
regarde aussi dans tous les pays
européens parce que moi j'ai quand même
pas mal voyagé dans le monde
que ça soit en Italie en Allemagne ou
ailleurs effectivement là je la retraite
a été repoussée mais c'est peut-être pas
la solution je suis pas à même de de
d'en parler je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de critères à prendre en
considération et de ce point de vue là
voilà nous ce qu'on veut c'est un
équilibre financier pour pas avoir plus
d'impôt sur le centre d'entreprise tout
simplement
et bien merci Thierry trevalinet d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je le rappelle
vous êtes le nouveau président du Medef
dans les Yvelines et on continue de
parler de la réforme des retraites les
syndicats appellent à une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme demain Céline Charle à quoi
faut-il s'attendre dans les Yvelines
alors comme pour les précédents
mouvements les syndicats appellent à la
grève dans les transports ou encore les
industries ce jeudi 16 février il
souhaite durcir le mouvement jusqu'au 7
mars date à laquelle ils disent vouloir
mettre la France à l'arrêt des
perturbations sont donc à prévoir mais
malgré tout cette grève devrait être
moins suivie que les précédentes dans
plusieurs secteurs et alors dans les
transports comment ça va se passer alors
dans les transports vous pouvez souffler
la SNCF annonce un trafic quasi normal
sur plusieurs grandes lignes du côté de
la RATP on retrouve un trafic normal à
légèrement perturbé pour le RER A et la
ligne u de train sur 3 pour les lignes J
et elle et un train sur deux pour la
ligne N concernant le RER B prévoyait
deux trains sur trois pour la liaison
entre gare du Nord Robinson et
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse n'hésitez pas à
vous rendre sur les sites de la RATP ou
transilia.com pour connaître le trafic
en temps réel à noter également qu'il de
France mobilité mais en place le
covoiturage gratuit même pour les
voyageurs sans passe Navigo rendez-vous
sur leur site internet pour plus
d'informations et alors dans les autres
secteurs à quoi faut-il s'attendre
Céline alors du côté des écoles la
mobilisation avait déjà reculé après le
premier jour le 7 février dernier on
observait selon les chiffres du
ministère de l'Éducation
14,17% d'enseignants grévistes contre
25,9 le 31 janvier un nouvel appel à une
journée d'action interprofessionnelle à
cependant été lancée par les différents
syndicats de l'enseignement mais
l'interdire syndical appelle surtout à
mettre les écoles établissements et
services à l'arrêt le 7 mars prochain
bien sûr pensez tout de même à vous
renseigner auprès de votre mairie pour
des informations plus précise notamment
concernant les établissements scolaires
dans les raffineries même si les
salariés comptent se mobiliser il n'y
aura pas d'arrêt de production de prévu
il n'y a donc aucun risque de pénurie
dans les stations d'essence et alors
dans les Yvelines il y a aussi une
manifestation qui est prévue alors tout
à fait le départ aura lieu à 10h à la
gare de chantier de Versailles direction
le Medef vendredi 17 février une
manifestation interditale aux flambeau
est également prévu à Rambouillet à
18h30 devant le nickel et comme je vous
le disais une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation et de grève et d'ores et
déjà prévus le 7 mars prochain et
celle-ci risque d'être beaucoup plus
suivi que les autres merci beaucoup
Céline char pour toutes ces précisions
alors Thierry trevalino on vient de
l'entendre il y aura une manifestation
qui part de la gare de Versailles
chantier qui ira jusqu'au Medef est-ce
que vous comptez dialoguer avec les
manifestants demain
on la connaît aujourd'hui
le dialogue est important donc oui le
Medef est toujours ouvert au dialogue
comme on le fait tous les jours avec nos
employés et nos collaborateurs oui
on sera là pour dialoguer sans sans
nulle de tous bien entendu et bien je
vous remercie encore Thierry trevalinet
d'avoir répondu à nos questions on prend
la direction de Houilles maintenant
depuis novembre les Yvelines ont lancé
un cycle de visite dans les 21 cantons
du territoire l'objectif dialoguer avec
les acteurs de la ville locale il y a
quelques jours le président de la
collectivité pierre Bédié c'est donc
rendu dans le canton de Houilles au
programme de ce déplacement notamment
une rencontre avec les maraîchers de la
plaine de Montesson le département est
actuellement en pleine réflexion pour
aller vers davantage d'indépendance
alimentaire le reportage de Grégory
canalet et Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
le quartier de la Défense n'est qu'à une
dizaine de kilomètres et pourtant ici on
cultive de la salade en grande quantité
23 millions de plans sur cette plaine de
montée sont considérés comme la capitale
francilienne de la plante potagère 250
hectares d'exploitation maraîchères à
monter son Sartrouville et
Carrières-sur-Seine sur lesquelles les
Yvelines compte s’appuyer pour aller
vers plus d'indépendance en matière
d'alimentation trouver des solutions et
des solutions durables et là parce que
les Yvelines se lancent dans un vaste
programme
d'autosuffisance alimentaire alors le
mot est un peu grand parce que on est
bien conscient que on y arrivera pas
mais on voudrait consommer de plus en
plus de produits Vinois et faire que les
produits Vinois deviennent majoritaires
dans l'assiette des Yvelines c'est
pourquoi une rencontre avec les
exploitants de la plaine étaient au menu
de la visite du canton de Houilles ces
maraîchers ont pu faire remonter au
président du Département quelques-unes
de leurs attentes pour améliorer leur
quotidien parmi eux Robert agriculteur à
Montesson depuis 1981 il y a certains
points d'amélioration qui à apporter sur
cette plaine notamment l'amélioration de
la structure foncière de la plaine on a
également un problème sur l'accès à
l'eau qui soit compatible en qualité en
quantité et surtout en prix avec notre
activité de production de légumes et
puis ensuite des accès à des marchés
publics divers pour l'ensemble de mes
collègues de la plaine de Montesson il
faut réfléchir à la façon dont on peut
les aider je pense que ça doit pouvoir
se faire après sur les questions de
fonciers donc d'acquisition foncière
c'est plus compliqué parce que les
sommes sont substantielles le
département a lancé des assises de
l'alimentation début février des groupes
de travail vont se réunir pendant 4 mois
avant l'annonce de mesure concrètes sur
le sujet
la prochaine visite du président du
département sera le 6 mars prochain
pierre Bédié se rendra dans le canton de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et comme chaque
mercredi maintenant nous partons à la
découverte d'une école ou d'une
formation sur le territoire des Yvelines
et c'est avec vous régénéralèch ce soir
vous allez nous parler de but ressources
oui c'est ça Mathilde on va parler de
ducressource et elle est spécialisée
dans les métiers du médico-social et ce
soir on va parler plus précisément du
diplôme pour devenir éducateur
spécialisé alors justement est-ce que
vous avez une définition de ce métier
éducateur spécialisé tout à fait c'est
une personne qui accompagne au quotidien
des enfants des adolescents ou des
adultes qui présentent un handicap
mental ou physique des difficultés
sociales ou d'insertion et l'éducateur
spécialisé permet à ces personnes de
devenir autonome de retrouver confiance
en elle ou bien d'apaiser un climat en
tension au sein d'une famille par
exemple et alors comment est-ce qu'on
fait régime pour devenir éducateur
spécialisé alors il faut obtenir un test
donc c'est le diplôme d'état d'éducateur
spécialisé c'est une licence donc ça se
fait en trois ans et à but ressource en
2022 92% des étudiants ont obtenu leur
diplôme pendant leur cursus les
étudiants alternent entre stages et
enseignements théorique il faut compter
60 semaines de stage sur les trois
années confondues et pour l'école il y a
une réelle intention de professionnels
les apprenants et de les confronter aux
réalités du terrain et comme vous l'avez
dit Mathilde justement avec nous
Charlène Garcia bonsoir donc vous êtes
éducatrice spécialisée ce que vous
pouvez nous parler un peu plus amplement
de votre expérience au sein de l'école
et quels sont les matières que vous avez
étudiées alors du coup à but ressources
on va travailler évidemment tout ce qui
est sociologie la psychologie on va
travailler les différents handicaps ou
aussi situation de vie que peuvent avoir
certaines personnes comme les SDF ou les
personnes souffrant d'addiction aussi et
tout ce qui est dans le champ de la
protection de l'enfance donc
le foyer pour enfants ou directement de
travailler au niveau des crises aussi
familiales donc finalement c'est quelque
chose qui est assez large oui c'est un
métier qui permet de changer
facilement de domaine en fait c'est ça
la richesse justement et justement cette
richesse vous avez pu l'exploiter au
travers de stage qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus dessus oui
source souvent on essaye de préconiser
de faire dans les trois chambres donc le
champ de l'insertion le champ de la
protection de l'enfance et le champ de
l'handicap maintenant au niveau de
l'insertion c'est un champ qui est assez
difficile
d'accéder en tant que stagiaire parce
que les problématiques vont être
multiples on va être souvent sur des
personnes qui sont vraiment
marginalisées dans la rue rencontrant
des problèmes d'addictologie des
problèmes de situation aussi au niveau
des papiers pour rester en France etc
donc c'est un champ qui est assez dur à
intégrer en tant que stagiaire on va
dire ou alternant
moi j'ai pu faire notamment dans
l'handicap psychique en accompagnant des
personnes souffrant d'handicap
comme la schizophrénie la bipolarité
ensuite j'ai fait un stage en masse donc
maison d'accueil spécialisée qui
accompagne des personnes avec un
polyhandicap donc moteur et
psychique pardon et ensuite j'ai fait
dans un foyer pour enfants adolescent
donc une messe maison d'enfants à
caractère social on a beaucoup
d'heroglyphes
pour des jeunes de 13 à 18 ans pardon et
donc aujourd'hui vous travaillez dans
quoi après toutes ces expériences de
stage vous avez choisi quel domaine
alors là j'ai arrêté les foyers et je
suis dans un service éducatif de
proximité qui appartient comme un
bucrossos à la sauvegarde des Yvelines
donc il y a nous avons un service à
Saint-Cyr à Houilles et aux Mureaux pour
pour pouvoir regrouper et intervenir sur
toutes les Yvelines donc on a on
accompagne des adolescents
qui rencontrent une crise au sein de la
cellule familiale ou qui sont dans une
situation de marginalisation dont les
parents ne comprennent pas et ont besoin
d'un tiers justement pour apaiser et on
est souvent vu comme une alternative au
placement et donc quelle est la qualité
qu'il faut avoir absolument pour pour
faire ce métier là finalement
l'adaptation il faut s'adapter au public
toutes les personnes sont différentes on
a un besoin différent et des capacités
différentes et comme un éducateur
spécialisé doit faire un projet avec la
personne qui l'accompagne en fonction de
ses besoins de ses envies et de surtout
de ses capacités donc je dirais plus
l'adaptation l'écoute évidemment et la
bienveillance et qu'est-ce qui vous
plaît le plus dans ce métier qu'on peut
bouger on peut changer de personnes
accompagnées de services il y a beaucoup
de possibilités de la remise question
les formations c'est un métier très
riche sur l'humain où tout est basé sur
l'échange on travaille souvent en équipe
pluridisciplinaire à l'aide de
psychologues ça peut être aussi des
psychiatres des
ergothérapeutes vraiment ça peut être
très riche au niveau des métiers qui
nous accompagnent et donc j'imagine que
c'est un métier qui est pas toujours
évident au quotidien quelle distance ou
qu'elle proximité ce que vous pouvez
avoir avec les personnes que vous
accompagnez c'est la grande question de
l'éducation spécialisée durant ma
formation c'est une question qui est
très souvent abordée en cours notamment
parce que c'est vous qui choisissez la
distance je dirais pas qu'il y a une
formule magique qui fait que on n'y
pense pas à la maison et que le cerveau
est reposé directement
on essaye de nous dire de faire
attention de savoir prendre de la
distance et notamment s'il y a autant de
semaines de stage dans cette formation
c'est pour savoir si on est apte en fait
à en vivre et
de se sentir assez à l'aise aussi en
tant que vie professionnelle et vie
perso mais finalement c'est quelque
chose que vous jaugez en fonction en
fait des personnes que vous rencontrez
et en fonction des publics tous les
publics ça va pas être la même chose en
fonction de nous aussi notre personne
notre personnalité il y a des publics on
arrive plus à couper le cerveau quand on
rentre à la maison que d'autres
et le ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur indique qu'il y a une chute de
38% quant aux candidatures sur
parcoursup ce que vous pouvez nous dire
pourquoi et qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
faire justement pour attirer les jeunes
vers cette filière alors
quand j'ai commencé
je suis rentrée dans cette école à 18
ans et j'ai remarqué que c'était surtout
un métier de reconversion en fin de
compte parce qu'on en parle pas du tout
de ces métiers là c'est un métier
méconnu moi à l'époque je le connaissais
pas du tout j'ai dû un peu chercher même
beaucoup
je pense qu'à le salaire évidemment tout
augmente dans notre société actuelle et
c'est un salaire qui est quand même qui
commence assez bas donc à Microsoft on
peut devenir éducateur spécialisé mais
on peut être aussi moniteur éducateur et
AMP
j'ai pas les hiéroglyphes mais on est
plus sur un accompagnement éducatif et
médical avec une formation d'un an et
demi pour accompagner les personnes en
situation d'handicap moteur
principalement
c'est des métiers qui n'ont pas besoin
du bac et vu que c'est une
reconnaissance de
Bac + un bac + 2 à mon époque on va dire
que le salaire ne suivait pas non plus
donc j'ai pu discuter déjà avec des
jeunes et ils m'ont dit que c'était
notamment la première raison après je
pense qu'il y a aussi la difficulté
psychologique on va dire parce que
souvent on nous dit mais comment vous
faites pour supporter
on sait pas non plus comment on fait et
je pense que c'est pour ça que je vous
dis vraiment que c'est en fonction du
public qu'on accompagne et notre
personnalité qui fait qu'on arrive à
supporter les désarroi des personnes
qu'on peut accompagner et alors si vous
aviez un conseil à donner aux étudiants
au futur étudiants ou au lycéens qui
souhaiteraient rentrer dans cette école
pour leur donneriez quoi comme conseil
que si il pense que c'est le bon endroit
pour eux ils peuvent y arriver
maintenant après ça va être la prise de
recul moi je pense que c'est d'abord il
faut qu'on accompagne l'humain il faut
aller bien soi-même c'est le premier
conseil qu'on donne c'est si nous on a
réglé nos soucis personnels parce que
c'est un métier qui fait beaucoup écho
aussi à nos situations on va on
travaille la relation avec les parents
on travaille les traumatismes et nous
aussi en tant que travailleur on peut
avoir à faire à ça dans notre vie
personnelle et il faut être prêt à
pouvoir
par en rediscuter de sa vie personnelle
mais de se remettre là-dedans en
accompagnant les personnes qui sont en
train de le vivre justement
et bien merci beaucoup Charline Garcia
d'être venu parler de votre métier et
éducatrice spécialisée et puis de votre
ancienne école Buc ressources on va
passer à un tout autre sujet maintenant
ils vont participer à un raid
humanitaire pendant un peu plus d'une
semaine Clément Morrison et Flavien
Castanet bonsoir vous êtes à distance
avec nous
bonsoir alors
vous êtes à Biarritz mais vous à
Biarritz mais vous venez tout de même
des Yvelines vous venez de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et donc là vous
êtes à Biarritz parce que demain ce sera
le départ du 4L Trophy alors première
question est-ce que vous êtes pressé de
ce départ comment est-ce que vous vous
sentez
un jour du départ
alors oui on est très pressé mais
aujourd'hui on a surtout été très
stressé parce que aujourd'hui il y a eu
des contrôles techniques et il y a eu
des petits problèmes au dernier moment
qui se sont qui viennent de se régler
donc maintenant oui on est pressé de
partir et
on peut partir
c'est une première participation pour
vous
oui
d'où le fait d'être un peu stressé je
suppose
exactement on savait pas trop comment ça
allait se passer cette journée de
contrôle et ben on a beaucoup appris
mais il y avait des petites choses qui
n'allaient pas
de surprises des petits surprises
heureusement le contrôle technique est
passé et allant de nos deux journalistes
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude et Gabriel
Gonthier vous ont suivi pendant votre
préparation on regarde tout de suite le
reportage
[Musique]
à 22 ans Ligny Montain Clément Morichon
s'apprête à vivre une aventure hors du
commun avec son coéquipier Flavien
Castanet il s'élanceront pour l'édition
2023 du 4L Trophy mais avant le grand
départ l'heure est à la préparation pour
Clément là je suis en train de préparer
le 4L Trophy donc là c'est tout le
matériel que je vais emmener pour si
jamais j'ai un pépin mécanique chose que
j'espère arrivera jamais mais donc du
coup voilà je mets tout donc là c'est
tout ce qui va être côté sécurité la
course se déroule en dans le désert
l'équipement de sécurité et d'entretien
du véhicule et primordial du coup c'est
extincteur donc ça c'est les lampes de
détresse si jamais je suis perdu dans le
dans le désert et après donc une
batterie de rechange si j'ai un accident
le triangle mon matériel c'est jamais
j'ai besoin de faire de la mécanique sur
sur la 4L après ici on va avoir tous les
produits d'entretien et pour faire les
mécaniques liquide de refroidissement
qui super important dans le désert
et puis après ici ça va être toutes les
parties mécaniques donc là ça va être
tout ce qui va être système de
refroidissement les pales de
ventilateurs les durites une fois le
contrôle de l'inventaire fait petit tour
du côté de la voiture donc là du coup la
voiture elle date de 1984 c'est une
fourgonnette F6
1100 cm cube c'est un moteur Cléon donc
radiateur à l'avant et donc du coup bah
là on a moi sur ce moteur là j'ai
surtout touché à tout ce qui est donc du
coup carburateur et allumeur mais pour
la faire démarrer l'étudiant a dû se
mettre à la mécanique je n'y connaissais
rien du tout au début c'est vraiment
j'ai tout appris sur Youtube c'est ça un
peu la force de notre génération
maintenant c'est que tu peux tout
regarder tout apprendre sur sur Youtube
et sur les forums tout ça l'équipage a
également du aménager le véhicule qui va
aussi être le lieu de vie pendant la
course du coup ce qu'il faut savoir
derrière c'est qu'on a fait donc du coup
un aménagement on a refait toute la
menuiserie à l'intérieur donc là en fait
là ça va être ça va nous permettre de
dormir dessus donc en avançant un petit
peu les sièges je peux baisser la plaque
j'ai un mètre 75 pour pour dormir en
dessous
exactement la chambre à coucher après il
manque juste un petit matelas pour pour
être tranquille et après en dessous donc
là ici j'aurais des baquets donc que je
suis en train de préparer là on aura
deux grands tiroirs pour mettre mes
pièces mécaniques ici
à côté on aura des petits paquets en
plastique pour nos vêtements et puis
tous les vivres qu'on aura besoin parmi
leurs équipements également de nombreux
sacs et fournitures seront distribués
dans les villages aux enfants
des sacs avec donc s'il y a pas de silo
faut que je mette des stylos et on
mettra des je vais mettre des cahiers
dedans agis - 1 avant le départ des 1200
voitures participantes l'objectif pour
le duo yvelinois est avant tout d'aller
au bout de l'aventure et de soutenir
l'association Les Enfants du désert
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
décidé de vous lancer dans cette dans
cette aventure Clément mauricon et
Flavien Castanet
tout d'abord pour le Défi donc ça soit
l'autonomie que ça soit avant le raid
pour la préparation mécanique trouver
des sponsors gérer une association et
après oui
le côté humain est aussi aventure
au Maroc avec une voiture c'est pas trop
avant on a préparé nous-mêmes et après
là-bas c'est de l'entraide c'est aider
les autres galères nous aussi on a un
problème on espère que viendront nous
aider
vraiment le côté humain et aventure
oui parce que vous allez traverser donc
trois pays la France l'Espagne jusqu'au
Maroc vous allez vous arrêter à
Marrakech à bord d'une 4L une voiture
quand même assez ancienne on l'a vu dans
le reportage il faut avoir des
connaissances mécaniques c'était pas
trop dur d'acquérir toutes ces
connaissances mécaniques
non
c'est du plaisir de d'apprendre
justement dans le domaine qui est la
mécanique
Régine vous aviez une question oui j'ai
une question est-ce que vous avez une
idée de combien d'heures vous allez
pouvoir par jour
on va être ouais sur du 5-6 heures
minimum par jour après par exemple
aujourd'hui pour venir à Biarritz hier
pardon pour venir à Biarritz on a roulé
10h de route
on avait 800 km à faire après par jour
on aura on va dire entre 100 et 200 km à
faire par jour mais ce sera dans
d'autres conditions et peut-être pas sûr
de la salle et donc ça va votre 4L elle
a tenu la route pour de Paris enfin de
Montigny jusqu'à Biarritz
la mécanique a bien marché on est
content donc sauf le petit problème sur
le longeron trop performant
toi un raid humanitaire puisque le but
c'est quand même d'aider l'association
Enfants du Désert vous allez distribuer
des fournitures scolaires dans des
villages marocains est-ce que vous savez
déjà dans quel village vous allez devoir
vous arrêter
non alors là c'est vraiment le but du 4L
c'est que une fois qu'on arrive à Tanger
on nous donne un petit robot qu'à la
boussole et on connaît pas le
l'itinéraire qu'on va faire mais on sait
qu'on va passer dans plein de petits
villages c'est ça
on ne sait pas lesquels
et donc à bord de votre 4L vous avez
quoi des stylos des cahiers
des classeurs des sacs pas mal de sacs
de notre école
et
quelques trous
et donc vous allez devoir vous orienter
uniquement avec un GPS enfin ça va vous
êtes bon en orientation si jamais il y a
des coupures
on sait lire une boussole et puis c'est
l'aventure encore une fois c'est
l'aventure
ça vous tenterait vous autour du plateau
de partir à l'aventure comme ça de faire
le 4L Trophy ah ouais totalement ouais
Régine
moi aussi surtout que c'est pour une
bonne cause donc finalement elle y est
aventure et solidarité pourquoi pas oui
au revoir l'orientation mais
pour la bonne cause évidemment et alors
je vous pose aussi la question Tony
chassez vous allez parler dans un
instant de votre nouveau court-métrage
jamais sans mon tel mais est-ce que du
coup ça tenterait cette aventure pour la
bonne cause toujours que des partants
autour de la table est-ce que on pourra
suivre vos aventures sur les réseaux
sociaux
oui on a un compte Instagram
les sièges 4L 2023 où on mettra toute
notre aventure sur sur Instagram et
après sur nos réseaux sociaux
et puis ben on vous suivra tout du long
de cette aventure merci en tout cas à
vous Clément Morichon et Flavien
Castanet d'avoir accepté notre
invitation bonne course
merci beaucoup bonne continuation
allez maintenant on va passer à notre
page au cinéma
[Musique]
et donc on débute cette page cinéma avec
vous Tony chasselas bonsoir vous êtes de
la verrière et vous avez sorti votre
cinquième court métrage jamais sans mon
tel alors rapidement c'est l'histoire
d'un jeune qui doit passer trois jours
sans son téléphone portable son
téléphone portable tout court pour en
fait valider le mystérieux testament de
sa grand-mère alors pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez décidé d'écrire de tourner ce
court métrage parce que c'est ce qui
m'est arrivé en fait je me suis retrouvé
sans téléphone portable pendant
plusieurs jours et l'aventure a été
folle en fait parce que j'étais plus du
tout habitué à me retrouver sans
téléphone portable je me suis dit que ça
pourrait être amusant de partager
l'expérience c'est d'en faire une
histoire donc j'ai décidé d'écrire le
film comme ça oui parce que finalement
son téléphone portable on s'en sert pour
tout aujourd'hui
c'est un défi que vous pourriez relever
autour du plateau passer trois jours
sans son téléphone ce sera compliqué
c'est je pense que ça serait très très
difficile mais c'est vrai que pour nous
en fait c'est un outil de travail au
téléphone portable donc même pour vous
Charline Garcia je suppose alors nous on
fait le combat avec les jeunes de lâcher
d'accord nous on aimerait bien qu'il
fasse trois jours sans au plus grand
bonheur des parents aussi mais je trouve
d'ailleurs que la difficulté c'est aussi
que ça remplace des objets du quotidien
parce que maintenant on achète plus
forcément de réveil notre téléphone
c'est notre réveil enfin c'est ah oui
c'est vrai
encore à ce niveau là mais bientôt moi
je paye avec mon téléphone aussi
ah oui c'est vrai bah ouais bah oui tout
ce qui est en ligne on peut payer avec
mon téléphone il y a nos mails le GPS la
musique il y a tout quoi toutes nos
questions aussi une recette internet
exactement c'est compliqué un jour
peut-être deux jours déjà c'est
difficile 3 jours ça devient ça devient
long
donc on va parler de votre court-métrage
dans un instant mais juste avant je
voudrais qu'on regarde le teaser
justement sur jamais sans mon tél
[Musique]
je serai chez vous jeudi soir
alors dans ce teaser on voit deux
acteurs Willy et Régis
Ivanov quels sont les autres acteurs que
vous avez choisi qui joue dans ce
court-métrage alors il y a Maurice El
Gourdon qui joue la grand-mère qu'on a
pu voir dans comment s'appelle la série
déjà
appelé mon agent en français 10% voilà
Louise Compain qu'on voit là récemment
la vue dans Netflix dans la série en
place et il y a deux trois autres rôles
mais c'est vraiment des petits rôles
c'est des rôles secondaires vraiment et
donc vous avez tourné dans les Yvelines
on peut apercevoir quelques images dans
quel lieu est-ce que vous avez tourné
j'ai tourné à la verrière principalement
les extérieurs à la gare de la verrière
il y a la mairie aussi j'ai tourné dans
la mairie de La Verrière grâce à Nicolas
Dainville le maire qui m'a prêté la
mairie pendant toute une journée donc on
a tourné également Élancourt dans le
cinéma ou le film va être projeté
à Coignières et mort pas donc c'est pas
la première fois que vous tournez un
court-métrage dans les Yvelines vous
êtes attaché au territoire
en fait c'est un lieu où j'ai adoré
grandir j'y vis encore je pense que je
partirai pas en tout cas pas tout de
suite c'est pas prévu et non je trouve
que c'est une belle ville j'ai appris
plein de choses là-bas on a une
mentalité assez particulière souvent
quand je rencontre des gens de Paris ou
autre
ils se rend compte que dans les Yvelines
en tout cas et dans la verrière le
Menier l'élancourt on a vraiment une
mentalité particulière en fait donc moi
je veux représenter ça et je trouvais
important de de tourner de là où je
viens en fait pas tourner dans des
endroits qui me correspondent pas
forcément des endroits que je connais
et donc vous avez reçu trois fois le
prix du meilleur court-métrage
indépendant au film au Festival du film
de Paris New York et Milan c'est un plus
pour votre carrière je suppose
la reconnaissance parce que c'est pas
des festivals avec du copinage c'est des
personnes qui me connaissent pas donc
ils jouent vraiment mon travail en fait
c'est vrai c'est pas parce que je suis
un tel qui est dans telle société de
production que je gagne le prix c'est
vraiment parce que mon projet l'aura et
alors vous travaillez sur ce
souvent des projets qui qui sont blonds
oula je crois que j'ai commencé en
janvier l'année dernière
d'accordage on a tourné en mai en mai de
l'année dernière avril mai de l'année
dernière et donc pour pouvoir réaliser
un court-métrage de 30 minutes il faut
une équipe de combien de personnes
autour on était entre 10 et 15 en
général entre 10 et 15 personnes sur sur
le film on a tourné une fois c'est
toujours et une autre fois on a dû
tourner trois jours je crois et vous
avez d'autres projets à venir ou pas là
j'ai une série qui
s'appelle godgame que j'ai tourné en
2019 ou 2020 avec le covid je sais plus
trop et en fait j'ai gagné pas mal de
prix pour cette série j'ai gagné 15 prix
et du coup je dois faire la première
saison cette année j'ai fait aussi un
crowdfunding pour récupérer quelques
financements et pouvoir tourner la
première saison
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
si vous souhaitez regarder jamais sans
mon tél rendez-vous samedi à 16h30 au
ciné 7 de Élancourt on va passer
maintenant à notre coup de cœur ciné par
un professionnel du 7e art alors comme
vous êtes réalisateur vous êtes dans le
milieu du cinéma est-ce que vous avez un
film favori Tony chasselas
fantômes SOS Fantômes pourquoi ben en
fait je l'ai je crois que c'est une des
premières cassettes vidéos que j'ai eu
quand j'étais petit parce que je suis
connu les cassettes vidéos et en fait je
les regarde en boucle donc là encore
aujourd'hui quand je le regarde je
connais tout par cœur et c'est vraiment
un film qui m'inspire et que
généralement j'aime bien regarder pour
me donner du peps je le ramène avec moi
en voyage quand je vais à l'étranger je
le ramène faut que je regarde au moins
une fois donc c'est ça se passe à New
York donc c'est une ville que j'adore
aussi donc vous avez un fort
rattachement sentimental on va regarder
le coup de cœur d'un autre réalisateur y
il s'agit de Thomas Salazar il vous
parle de twenty one Jump Street regardez
[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vous
parlais de mon coup de coeur il s'agit
du film twenty one Jump Street de Phil
Lord et Chris Miller sorti en 2012 alors
il s'agit d'une adaptation de la série
du même nom des années 80 qui est
notamment à rendu célèbre un petit
acteur qui s'appelle Johnny Depp et donc
c'est l'histoire d'un Joe de policiers
un petit peu tête en l'air casse-cou qui
se retrouve en mission d'infiltration
dans un lycée où ils doivent découvrir
un petit peu les rouages d'un trafic de
drogue dans ce lycée les deux
personnages sont interprétés par Jonah
Hill et Channing Tatum qui forment
vraiment un duo comique incroyable
cartoonesk vraiment des des fous rires à
en pleurer tu veux bien avec mon
cavalier au bal sortir la poubelle non
là on a pas le temps de faire la bonus
notamment aussi avec leur chef qui est
joué par le rappeur Ice Cube voilà un
petit caméo qui fait vraiment plaisir
très bon aussi très rigolo c'est parce
que vous êtes des clones de Justin
biberon et de Miley Cyrus que vous êtes
ici le rythme est parfait on est dans un
dans un un univers de lycée totalement
décalé et on a aussi en fond quand même
une belle histoire d'amitié comment
est-ce que des amitiés peuvent se souder
se dessouder par rapport à la popularité
tout ce monde du lycée qui est au final
très cruel le lycée avec avec les gens
populaires et un populaire voilà bref je
vous conseille ce film twenty one James
Street de fill Lord et Chris Miller
[Musique]
alors est-ce que vous l'avez vu ce film
autour du plateau moi je l'ai vu vous
l'avez vu et du coup vous en pensez quoi
il était très drôle très drôle les
réalisateurs sont très forts et Jonah
aussi il est très bon dedans
Charlène Garcia c'est génial je ne l'ai
pas vu
et c'est bien pour se détendre
en tout cas moi j'ai bien aimé le coup
de coeur la bande-annonce etc je pense
que je vais le mettre sur ma to do list
on poursuit cette page cinéma avec vous
c'est une Charles quels sont les sorties
cinéma ne pas manquer cette semaine
alors le premier film il s'agit Dante
Man et la guêpe quand tout Mania c'est
le dernier Marvel après le multivers de
Spider-Man ou Docteur Strange ce film
nous plonge dans le royaume quantique de
l'homme fourmi le super héros capable de
grandir et rétrécir à volonté un opus
qui va permettre de lancer la phase 5 de
l'univers cinématographique de Marvel et
de présenter le nouveau grand méchant
successeur de Thanos quand le Conquérant
Ant-Man coule des jours heureux à San
Francisco lorsque sa fille Cassie
devenue jeune adulte met au point un
appareil permettant d'explorer le
royaume quantique à la suite d'un
incident lui et tous ses proches vont se
retrouver propulser dans cet univers
je suis celui qui peut t'offrir la seule
chose que tu désires
c'est à dire du temps
[Musique]
il peut réécrire l'existence même
floquer des flux temporaires
ne lui accorde aucune confiance peu
importe qui est j'ai manqué trop de
choses
grâce à lui on pourra avoir une seconde
chance
vous nous proposez un autre film Céline
Charles il s'agit d'un thriller
psychologique ah oui c'est un tout autre
registre la femme de Tchaïkovsky est un
biopic de Kiril serré brennikov qui
explore la relation tumultueuse entre le
grand compositeur du 19e siècle et sa
femme Antonina alors Antonina épouse de
pianiste mais l'amour qu'elle lui porte
n'est pas réciproque pour cause il
préfère l'accompagner des hommes et il
va tout faire pour dégoûter Antonina
elle qui va se terrer dans le déni
jusqu'à ce que son mari et son amour
pour lui deviennent une obsession c'est
le récit d'une lente descente aux enfers
pour la jeune femme consumée par ses
sentiments regardez
[Musique]
et on termine votre sélection avec une
comédie française un homme heureux oui
un peu plus légèreté maintenant un homme
heureux de Tristan Ségala c'est la
Comédie Française de la semaine avec
Catherine frotte et Fabrice Luchini en
toi de fond la transidentité Jean est un
maire très conservateur en pleine
campagne de réélection qui va tomber de
haut lorsqu'elle dites son épouse va lui
faire une confession elle a toujours été
un homme et compte très vite entamé sa
transition alors c'est l'histoire d'un
couple qui va voir sa vie personnelle et
professionnelle complètement chamboulé
merci beaucoup Céline Charles est-ce que
vous avez un film que vous souhaitez
aller voir au cinéma qui vous tente plus
qu'un autre Tchaïkovski
je pense que ça peut être super intense
que l'histoire
moi aussi j'ai un penchant pour les pour
les thrillers psychologiques
Tony chasselas
tout à l'heure
c'est vraiment le film je pense pour les
passionnés de Marvel à ne pas manquer
cette année et vous Charlen Garcia je
prends le même avis que vos collègues
au cinéma c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission mais juste avant de se quitter
je tends un dernier coup d'oeil à la
météo de demain
[Musique]
c'était le dernier beau jour de
aujourd'hui de beau temps aujourd'hui
j'espère que vous en avez bien profité
demain matin nous devrions être dans le
brouillard sur l'ensemble du département
selon Meteo France au niveau des
températures il fera 6 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan et 5 degrés à
Versailles et Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi prévoyez un ciel couvert et
côté température il fera 11 à 9 degrés
en moyenne et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]